you're the Speaker of the House you're
the expert on this no doubt and you have
been on House Ways and Means to you know
Tax Policy but I'm looking at this
you've promised to make tax reform
revenue neutral and you've promised to
make it permanent yes and and you don't
have now the trillion dollars in taxes
from the Obamacare repeal and the border
adjustment tax which also would get you
about a trillion don't renew you've done
your you done your she's done your
homework on yes so here's how here's let
me go back that means we'll have to keep
those Obamacare taxes on the book so
that trillion dollars will stay a
trillion dollar tax increase on the
American economy through Obamacare we'll
have to leave that there and then we're
back to exactly what we were doing that
that's bad for the economy that's a drag
on the economy
all those Obamacare taxes hurt the
economy make health insurance more
expensive hurt things like our medical
devices that we use to keep our lives
healthier and longer those taxes will
have to remain and then we'll do what we
were always planning on doing is reform
the tax code the rest of the tax code
we're going to have lots of negotiations
all year long on how to get to tax
reform but it is crystal clear to any
economic observer who watches this the
American tax system is the most
uncompetitive one in the industrialized
world and this is critical for economic
growth and job creation that's why I'm
still confident we're going to get tax
reform because we Republicans this is in
our DNA cleaning up the IRS cleaning up
the tax code making America more
competitive getting jobs and
manufacturing restored to America
lowering our tax rates to make it smoke
about it that's something we all agree
on we don't have a schism whatsoever our
party on that and that's why I'm
confident we'll still get tax reform but
whilst I have this sore thumb sticking
out on the tax code which is a trillion
dollars of Obamacare taxes won't have
been repealed they'll still stay there
in place
do you have assurances that President
Trump will back the border adjustment
tax we're always talking about that so
we all of the features of the text hood
another thing is final until it's all
agreed to at the end of the day we're
having constant conversations with the
administration on these things so we
think it's it's 160 other countries do
we're penalizing american-made products
so we basically have tax laws that
penalize making things in America
reward outsourcing manufacturing we
think that's really stupid and we
shouldn't be doing that and that's why
we had this border adjustment